[Music]
all right you know what i
what i do want to show you is we talked
a lot about asian american hate and i
wanted a spotlight to make a couple
asian
asian americans
sorry i wanted to spotlight some asian
americans that have really added to our
culture
and i think this is a great way to end
this episode because i have a couple of
these
and i wanted to show you that where
would we be without great rappers
like is this guy not the oh god i really
thought he was the virginia tech shooter
when you pulled him up
oh yes because you're racist i know he
really does look like him though
uh let me tell you something the only
thing this guy's shooting is bars
okay yeah i mean
[Music]
i make it rain i'll make it i mean
yeah i mean i would too when this guy's
coming over and he's [ __ ] rapping
better than their rappers i get it
if he was playing golf as good as he was
rapping here you know
the white people would be more terrified
mm-hmm
i'm gonna tell you something also
youtube is responsible for this
anti-asian hate
explain why you know who they kicked off
of their platform they want them back on
filthy frank asian american
kicked them off of the platform they
didn't kick him off
yeah they kicked him off he's gone he
left yeah he left from the pressure
from youtube no he left because he
became some like
emo singer uh it's actually a k-pop band
that he's in
whatever k-pop or j-pop or one of those
pops
i don't know some kind of emo tech not
techno
i don't know some kind of weird [ __ ]
that he's into now and he did it himself
but there's nothing to do with being
asian uh let's hear some more flows
[Music]
[Music]
now you have to keep something in mind
in his waistband he doesn't rock a glock
he has a psp there
he's rocking a psp in his uh waistband
what about this though they did kick
warski off youtube and warski's channel
was at one time shared with a guy who
was like was he like a
[ __ ] or something i mean look what
they did to hank you
look what they did to hank you you want
to talk about
asian hate you want to talk about
[ __ ]
some heartbreaking racist [ __ ] that
happened to a man
that right there was it was it was a was
a travesty of justice
it was gross i'm sure he lied on his
federal
firearms paperwork yeah you know you
know who else did
hunter biden and he's doing fine
his dad's the president though oh yeah
you're right his dad's kamala harris
yes a lot of people don't know that i
[Music]
and where is he and why is he
i don't know there's just a myth it's a
mythic rapper then honestly this is what
they don't want you to see they don't
want you to see
the reason this is what i don't want me
to say
all right then how about this one no not
that i wouldn't really thought that was
the virginia tech shooter
like him and it looked like he had like
clips look like he had magazines
sticking out of his
uh belt now let's check this one out
this is a good one
this is what they bring to this country
and i think some of you guys are just
gross for not accepting it the virus
[Music]
that's where filthy frank is there he is
that is yeah that's what he was doing
he changed it got it isn't guilo like a
slur what is he saying about me this is
a slur isn't it
yeah know round eye or something
that's funny this [ __ ] slaps
[Music]
hey frozen what does guy low mean
[Music]
it [ __ ] slaps dude
honestly sounds like some kind of
wu-tang beat too for like a b-side
yeah i am wondering what guilo means a
weak
westerner they're saying no i don't
think i don't think that i thought it
was i thought it was round eye but maybe
he hits
wylo or quilo guilo
it's gwylo okay all right
all right fair enough um
while we're asking well we're asking all
these expert questions to frozen eight
a frozen asian when i in big trouble in
little china
here we go uh when lopez shoots the
lightning and bolts out of his eyes is
that like magic
or is it like some kind of religious
thing look how does that work
you guys train at that laser blue beam
coming out of the live thing or
is it like are you born with it like
x-men style
i do have another question for asian
because a couple because he's the best
one saying wylo is round eyes see i know
it
okay so another question for people for
for asian specifically
do asian women have sideways vaginas
i always heard that as a kid is that
true
yeah cause like i've seen pornos with
them in it and it doesn't look like they
do but i always thought they corrected
that well i don't know
all the points your pronouns i've seen
it's pixelated so i can't tell
true okay so i mean you know they don't
want us to see the sideways vaginas
that's the source of their power why do
you think they sex
traffic them it's it's it's a very high
commodity
uh imagine if they did have sideways
[ __ ] and
you could just make a killing as a
plastic surgeon
just turning turning [ __ ] [ __ ]
counterclockwise
i also realize that i'm asking frozen
i'm asking frozen asian
if he if asian women's uh [ __ ] are
sideways like he's ever seen a vagina
so i mean online money i'd make so much
money giving 90 degree
uh [ __ ] adjustments [ __ ]
surgeon shows up with a protractor yeah
just gotta twist this [ __ ] around turn
it i got it
i got this let's do it crop it like an
eye like a [ __ ] iphone
picture ah [ __ ] i went counterclockwise
i apologize
by your [ __ ] super sorry about that
although
all those shits are gonna be way more
fun for you now
we keep coming every time we take a dump
every time we have to wipe
yeah all right look i think that was the
classiest way we could have been in this
episode would you not agree
yeah i don't think we're gonna top that
did we solve asian american hate
i don't know who cares no one cares
asian